so first of all thanks for having me and
thanks for this kind introduction of
course thank you for your interest in my
talk about Python or using Python to
unit test smart contracts or a theorem
smart contracts hey hear me all right
okay and so yeah I said I'm in my
professional life I'm a data scientist
at flicks bus so usually I do machine
learning and time serious analysis and
and price optimization but about a year
ago I got infected by the cryptocurrency
fever as some people did and in my spare
time then I played around with
blockchain technology and one technology
in particular and that is etherium
because the theorem is pretty cool it's
a blockchain you can actually program
and just to emphasize this again so I do
this in my spare time so I'm by no means
at all an expert on etherium smart
contracts so if you really think about
releasing some a theorem contracts into
the while meaning deploying to the main
net feel free to approach me and we can
talk about this but please seek at
expert advice right because we will see
later on it's very very easy to lose a
lot of money on the blockchain
especially other people's money so yeah
but before digging into what he theorem
is and how you write smart contracts and
how you can actually then test them in
Python let's start with the very basics
so aetherium is a cryptocurrency which
is based as many others on blockchain
technology so what is the blockchain in
simple terms the blockchain is nothing
else but a distributed database where
you store so-called facts so facts are
just pieces of data that have been
verified to some extent to adhere some
certain rule sets that apply to this
particular blockchain and these facts
these pieces of verified data are
bundled together in so-called blocks so
this would be then the first block and
then the second block and as the name
suggests they are kind of chained
together so they are linked sequentially
and and you can actually count them so
like the first box usually the Genesis
block and the way they are linked is
usually by hashing so what you do
is you attached pretty much the label to
each of these blocks and the label is
the hash of the contents so the Genesis
block for example you would somehow take
the contents hash them and this would be
the unique label such as like for a good
commit that identifies this block and
then the linkage between the blocks is
actually established by not only hashing
the contents but also taking the hash of
the previous block in your hashing
operation and you can do this then in
subsequent steps and and by this you
form your form a chain and as I said
this this chain is shared across very
different nodes in the network usually a
couple of thousand nodes and all of them
keep an exact same copy of this block
chain sorry mm-hmm and most of the
complex and involved part of block
chains is about actually getting new
data into the block chain and making
sure that then still everyone has the
exact same copy of this block chain so
there might be some free-floating facts
that haven't been checked yet but that
want to become part of this block chain
and there are certain people who take
care that new data can be inserted into
this distributed database and these are
the so-called prominent miners so the
job of the miners is to actually collect
verify and combine new facts into new
blocks and then once they come up with a
new block they have to do the so called
proof of work so the proof of work
essentially is just a very expensive
computational operations to make coming
up with new blocks very very difficult
and we'll see in a minute more we need
this and these miners are not doing this
for the the good sake of mankind but
they do this because they get rewarded
for it so there's some monetary reward
in for them for actually creating new
blocks and then they can actually
publish new blocks and we can extend the
blockchain and there might be other
nodes in the network as well which are
not necessarily - but there could be
passive nodes and their job is then just
taking these new blocks and actually
verifying that also the miner
did a proper job and that they verified
the data correctly that they came up
with a correct proof of work and so on
so what is this mysterious proof of work
this mysterious proof of work is also
based on hashing so it's the cornerstone
here is cryptographic hash functions so
a cryptographic hash function is simply
a function that takes an input message M
of arbitrary length and digests it to a
fixed length output here D so usually
let's say 256 bits so just a stream of
zeros and ones and what is so beautiful
about these cryptographic hash functions
is there are it's infeasible to actually
revert this operation so in order to
come up with a D that has a particular
shape the only thing you can do is
actually brute force trying to guess
different messages that you put into
this cryptographic hash function and
actually this is what miners have to do
when they solve the proof-of-work so
basically the proof of work states that
your miner you're allowed to change the
message as you like but you have to come
up with a hashtag s that is small enough
or you might think of it as that has a
sufficient amount of leading zeros right
and this is incredibly complicated
because sometimes these this can be up
to 40 leading zeros and the message the
the miners are allowed to put into this
cryptographic hash function consists of
two parts so the first one is called the
challenge this one's going to be fixed
but the other one is called the proof so
this is the one they can actually in a
brute-force mana or iteratively change
in order to guess a good hash digest so
this could be just the integers that
they start counting 1 2 3 4 and so on
and this is actually this is oh this is
all the proof of work is just trying to
guess an input to come up with a hashtag
S that has the sufficient amount of
leading zeros and usually this is as I
said quite expensive so there might be
billions and billions of hashes involved
that they need to compute ok so how does
it not work if a miner wants to produce
a new block
so let's say our current head of the
blockchain is Blockade so this is the
news book that is available and there
are some free-floating facts around and
the first thing the miner does is
actually verify the facts so he checks
that these facts adhere to the rules set
at hand and once he's verified the fact
he's allowed to create a new fact for
himself because as we said they are
rewarded for this so they can create a
new fact that in somehow states this
miner is rewarded for his work and then
he takes all the facts pairs them
concatenates them and past the hashes
sorry and hashes the pairs of these
facts and then it takes the hashes of
the hashes pairs them and hashes them
and he does this until he reads leads to
such a rout of such a hashing tree which
was called Merkel tree which is then
pretty much the hash of the content of
this particular block he's going to
produce and then he takes the hash value
of the previous block and combines it
with the hash of the contents and hash
it is again and this is then going to be
so the hash value of this combination is
then going to be the hash value of this
block so this is then the label that is
attached to this block and it's also
going to be the challenge string for
this proof of work so so far this was
already a lot of hashing but now comes
the action involves part like now starts
the real hashing because now the miner
has to come up with a proof of work that
combines with this hash value of the
block actually gives the hash digest
that has a sufficient amount of leading
zeros let's say 40 leading zeros see the
exact amount of leading zeros actually
depends on the blockchain at hand so for
example on for Bitcoin this is dynamic
and it's chosen such that on average
every 10 minutes the new block is
produced and once he succeeds in
actually finding appropriate proof
string
he just publishes the new block and the
proof string
to the network and then everyone else
can actually check that the miner did a
did a proper work so he would go along
hey other notes in the network I found a
new block I found a appropriate proof of
work here is the new block and then
everybody would again check that the
miner did a proper job which means are
the facts true is the proof of work true
and if if that's the case then we enter
new data into this database and and this
is how you extend them the blockchain so
what are these facts actually so for
Bitcoin these facts are just
transactions right so facts could be
something like Alice sends 20 Bitcoin to
Bob or Bob sends 60 Bitcoin to Charlie
or facts could be stuff like new 50
bitcoins Alice because she mind this
block and she's rewarded for this so she
can create Bitcoin out of thin air and
checking these facts just now involves
making sure that the people spending
money actually have the appropriate
funds to do so right
so if Alice wants to send 20 Bitcoin to
Bob in order to verify this fact the
miner has to check that Ellis actually
owns 20 Bitcoin you might wonder okay so
miners have to check transactions that
make sense right because people
shouldn't spend money they don't have
but why do we need this expensive proof
of work this is so wasteful that is
billions of hashes that cost so much
energy well the reason is this is sort
of a replay protection and this is
actually the cornerstone of the
blockchain that makes it secure because
assume that the proof of work was not
expensive and we could easily create new
blocks let's say Ellison bought meat and
negotiate over let's say a car for 50
Bitcoin then Bob gives Ellis the car
Alice sends 50 Bitcoin to Bob everyone's
happy because Ellis owns the car Bob has
50 Bitcoin but now Alice's mean and
actually creates just new blocks right
before this block where the transaction
to block was mine because in this
hypothetical example creating new blocks
is easy because there's no important or
difficult proof of work
she could simply start overtaking the
blockchain with new blocks and thereby
pretty much rendering this transaction
invalid or from the perspective of the
blockchain this transaction has never
happened because the protocol dictates
that the true blockchain is always the
longest blockchain so in this case then
she would actually have the car and the
50 Bitcoin and bought well he lost
everything and this is the reason why we
need this expensive proof of work to
make this situation pretty much
impossible okay so this was the this was
the basics of blockchain and now let's
move over to aetherium so aetherium is
pretty much similar as the stuff we've
seen before so it's it's very similar to
Bitcoin it's also a crypto currency
there the units are not called Bitcoin
but simply called ether and it's also as
we've seen before in this fortune exam
is just a distributed database but the
difference is now what we can store as
these facts into this database so for
Bitcoin we've seen these facts are just
transactions but for aetherium the new
thing is you can of course store
transactions so we can send around this
ether but you can actually store
arbitrary data into this blockchain and
arbitrary data means you can actually
store executable code so you can you can
write programs onto this blockchain and
these programs are called in the
terminology of a theorem and and other
and other cryptocurrencies are called
smart contracts so so pretty much then
whatever can so these facts that now can
be stored on the database can be
summarized as transactions bytecode of
compiled programs and of course
persistent data so it pretty much this
is how the etherium blockchain looks
like so the etherium blockchain now
lives in the so called a theorem virtual
machine which means whenever you deploy
stuff to the blockchain that is a
program that gets executed by the miners
and other nodes within this sandbox if
you're in virtual machine so a
blockchain might look like this so in
the Genesis block
ls- block so she gets a reward 15 ether
for the 50th for this and of course you
can have transactions as before like
sending around ether so like Ellis sends
20-30 Bob but now the new stuff you can
do is there might be transactions that
go like this
Alice deploys the buy code of the
program that she written that is called
slot machine dot soul and from then on
this program lives on the blockchain and
can be used by other people so there
might be some later interactions with
the blockchain of other accounts and
other users so BOTS might actually sent
three ether to this smart contract and
call the function pool ever because he
might want to win some money but he
loses and then the three ether are
sought by the contract and could maybe
later be withdrawn by Ellis because she
brought the contract okay so what is now
the job of the miners in etherium so
it's actually very similar to what we've
seen before
so of course their job is data
collection and verification so they have
to check if you eat the transactions so
they have to make sure that people who
spend funds on the blockchain actually I
have the appropriate amount of money
available but also they have to execute
contract code in the etherium virtual
machine and this might incorporate stuff
like creating new contract instances as
we've seen before
Alice deploys the slot machine dot saw
it might be other people actually
executing functions on these contracts
and during these functions executions
actually the persistent state of these
contracts might change so for example in
this pool ever in this pool ever
function call we've seen before
you could have a persistent state
variable that just counts how many
people actually pull the lever already
and you would just start counting
whenever somebody pulls the lever and
then this state variable which is just
an integer would be persistently stored
on the blockchain and every time
increased somebody pulls the lever and
then again they have to do the proof of
work and of course they get rewarded for
doing this expensive calculations and
finally once they six
in doing the proof-of-work they of
course have to again publish the new
block and then all the other nodes have
to check that the miners did a proper
job
so aetherium brands itself as the world
computer which it kind of is because
basically your your program gets
executed by a lot of people but it's a
very inefficient one because these nodes
checking that the miners did a proper
job also have to re execute the code so
whatever you deploy to the blockchain is
going to be executed at thousands of
times just to make sure that your
program does what it's supposed to do
okay let's come to the actual
programming part and doing stuff on the
blockchain and first disclaimer contract
programming is incredibly hard the
problem is once you deploy to the
blockchain actually updating stuff is
close to impossible and because of this
they have been like there's a almost
infinite list of errors that people code
it into their programs that led to loss
of millions and millions of dollars and
I just pick two the most the most famous
ones so the first one is the so called
dowel hex so dowel stands for digital
autonomous organization and it's pretty
much like a Kickstarter implementation
on a blockchain so you could transfer
funds to this dowel smart contract and
then this dowel smart contract would
fund other projects and but also since
you could send money there you could
also withdraw your money and somebody
actually managed to withdraw all the
money by a recursive execution of a
function and this exploit wasn't known
at that point in time and so when when
this guy did about 50 million u.s.
dollars at that point in time were lost
which correspond to 15% of all ether in
circulations that was a that was a big
flaw and actually because it involved
like more than 10% of the ether
something very revolutionary happened
because the entire a theorem community
came together and said we we can't let
this happen
so what they did is they actually rolled
back the blockchain fixed the back and
said this transaction never happened so
there was like a massive social
consensus all over the internet across
lots of different and also anonymous
people except for liable a small group
of people actually were very pissed
about this and they said you shouldn't
do this you shouldn't roll back
blockchains code is law and because of
this a second cryptocurrency was born
aetherium classic where they kept this
transaction and where they said okay so
we're the rebels here and we're just
gonna have our own cryptocurrency now
there was another big hack more recently
which is called the parity funds freeze
so parity is a smart contract that just
instantiates a wallet so pretty much it
just stores ether for you in a kind of
more fancy way with a bit more tools
around it the problem was that somebody
with the github name dev ops 1999 was
actually able to took ownership of a
library that was powering this wallet
and then exit just by executing
functions on the blockchain was able to
kill that library and make it unusable
forever like it's dead and as a
consequence of this everybody who used
these wallets can no longer move their
funds so by the point in time that was a
hundred fifty million u.s. dollars
probably nowadays it's even more and
because I mean the cryptocurrency space
got a bit bigger and there's more money
involved this is no longer on the order
of 15 a theorem 15 percent of a theorem
and circulation so this actually did not
justify for a rollback of the blockchain
so these people are well their money is
stuck probably forever yeah so as I said
contract program is hard and it's very
easy to make very costly mistakes so
testing is of utmost importance probably
even more important than in the regular
IT world but and the beauty here is you
can do this in Python for ëthere iam
smart contracts and this library is
called populous so if you manage to pip
install populous which is still kind of
developmental so there might be a few
hiccups but let's assume you actually
managed to install his library and then
you call populist in it on your command
line and
we'll give you as a hello world example
of an aetherium smart contract and their
hello world example of how to test it so
so this is then the example they give
you I don't want to go into details but
what you can see here this is the
solidity language so this is the
language of choice to write smart
contracts for the etherion blockchain it
looks a lot like and has been heavily
inspired by JavaScript sorry I'm sorry
about this but the good news is the
testing part of it can be done in Python
with the populist library and this is
exactly what we want to do now so I just
want to quickly caught up with you a
little game that we're gonna play on the
etherium blockchain and write the
corresponding tests to it so like little
live demo they always tell you doing
demo let's give it a try okay can you
see this should I make it a bit bigger
or
Aion is that big enough okay I mean even
if I mess it up right now I have all the
stuff prepared so I can just go the full
TV chef I have something prepared for
you here so okay so let's write our
first smart contract is this little
snowballs game I have in mind and the
game is actually very silly and very
easy and so what we want to do is create
a game where you can throw snowballs at
other people and and the only thing that
happens if you throw a snowball at
someone he's gonna keep that snowball
and is able to throw snowballs at other
people and also you get rewarded for
just throwing snowballs with more
snowballs okay so as I said contracts
are called programs are called smart
contracts so in order to start a smart
contract the key word here of course is
contract and then we give it a name and
like the Python analogue here would be
simply a Python class and if you then
deploy to the blockchain pretty much
you're instantiated contract and
corresponds to a Python object and
similar to Python objects you can have
of course attributes or state variables
and let's just add one state variable
called mapping so a mapping is pretty
much like a dictionary in Python but a
very bare bone one that just has a
default value of zero so if the key is
not present then the corresponding value
is just going to be zero and we're gonna
have one mapping from addresses so this
is our just like users in of the
blockchain two integers and let's call
this balances so this is just gonna be a
mapping that stores the amount of
snowballs somebody has right and then as
most Python classes have we need an init
function which in the very new forms of
solidity is called constructor and and
it just goes like this so what are we
going to do when we initially initialize
this class which just means we're going
to deploy to a blockchain
I think it's just fear that if I just
get 100 snowballs I mean I invented the
game so this should be fair so there's
this keyword message sender which is
always the guy executing the function
and the constructor can only be executed
by me once I deploy to the blockchain
and I'm just going to get 100 snowballs
so now we've written our first contract
which is pretty silly because the only
thing it does is giving me a hundred
snowboards but let's start with the
first test of oops that's the wrong fire
let's start with the first test of this
and so let's just test if if we actually
succeeded in giving me a net snowballs
so then we can use simple PI test
functions which just start with the word
test right and now comes the beauty of
popular so populous already gives you a
lot of fixtures that you can use in your
code and one of these fixtures the
testing fixtures is the so-called chain
so basically what populus does is
creating an in-memory block chain for
you that you can use so we can now
deploy to this blockchain Populus will
take care of all the nitty-gritty
details like miners mining stuff
collecting transactions verifying
transactions and the only thing we have
to care about is our contract
another nice fixture it provides is the
so-called accounts so it will create 10
accounts for us and the first account is
just going to be me ok let's deploy this
to the blockchain using Python you can
do it like this
Jane dot provider so let's get or deploy
contract and we have to give it the name
of the contract did I write it with L
with an S or without without it snowball
and then we can write our first test and
the only thing we have to test is that I
get the appropriate amount of snowballs
which is just my contract please check
if I ask for the balances of
me which is the first accountant this
should be 100 snowballs and let's see if
it works and alright it works
I actually surprised that it works the
first time so we've written our first
test and we've seen that okay so I can
assign myself 100 snowballs let's do one
more thing and extend the contract to
actually incorporate parts of the game
let's in create a function where you can
actually throw snowballs
okay so let's call this function throw
ball and it takes one parameter the the
target user so the guy I'm actually
throwing snowballs at and of course we
just want to make sure that only people
can participate in the game who actually
own snowballs so you can use this nice
required statement which checks for
boolean conditions that have to be true
in order to execute this function and as
I said we just want to make sure that
the guy who ever calls this function so
again this is the smashed message sender
has the appropriate amount of snowballs
so it has at least one snowball and yeah
JavaScript so we have to stop with a
semicolon and and then parts of the game
then are that me or the guy throwing the
snowball is rewarded with more snowballs
let's say two but also the guy who got
hit and is rewarded with a single
snowball so he got to keep the snowball
so this is now our game let's write one
more test for this huh oh yeah pub
Thanks yeah we need this keyword
otherwise people can't call this
function from the outside on the
blockchain and there we go let's create
a new test to find test throw ball again
we use the blockchain we use the the
accounts and I'm just gonna copy and
paste this deployment here
okay so now throwing a ball is actually
a transaction on the blockchain and so
now we have to say please dear contract
transact the following transaction which
is just throwing the ball transact and
this is the function that we now call on
the blockchain throw a ball and let's
take as a target the second account and
then now because this is a national
transaction that's carried out by the
blockchain we have to wait until it's
mined and you can do this with the
following statement chain wait for
receipt and please wait for this
transaction and this should actually
then wait until we throw the snowball
and it's by default so you can actually
pass a dictionary here where you can set
who is the thrower but by default it's
going to be account one account zero so
the first of the accounts and and it's
right just one test and that actually
the guy we throw that now owns the
snowball call balances
okay so let's see if our test succeeds
all right it does so it works so what we
just did is deployed the our little game
to this in memory blockchain and then we
threw a ball which is a transaction and
then we checked that and the guy who
threw the ball that actually has one new
ball okay yeah we could of course we
should check that too but in the
interest of time I'll leave that as an
exercise to the reader and there's
there's one more thing
so with coding up this very little game
and only these few lines of code I
already introduced probably a big error
into this game that can be exploited by
players and this is I didn't check that
I throw the stuff at myself right so I
could just exploit this and then throw
snowballs at myself and I would
instantly get three more snowballs three
miles north and this is probably not
what this game is about
so you've seen even with a few
statements we were already able to
create a big mess so if I actually had
deployed this to the real blockchain and
already had some people playing the game
and then I realized oh I have to fix
this error because I don't want people
throwing it themselves the only way to
fix this would be to create a new
contract deploy it and then convince all
the gamers to move from the old game to
the new game okay sorry and that's
pretty much about it there's a few
take-home messages so first of all just
as a short repetition so a theorem is
the supercool cryptocurrency that allows
you to run so-called smart contracts on
a blockchain and and then we've seen
there's this nice populist library that
you can use to actually test these smart
contracts in Python and actually writing
good solidity code is incredibly
difficult and it's super easy to
introduce errors that are very very
costly so that's that's about it thank
you very much and there is a few
references here so there's the link to
the populist library there's
documentation of the language there's a
cool IDE that you can use in your web
browser where you can actually instantly
deploy to the main or to the test net of
aetherium there is the meet our mask
browser plug-in which you should check
out because that's a very nice way to
interact with the blockchain directly in
your browser and there's this nice list
of ëthere iam hacks like there's tons of
them where people make very costly
mistakes and it's it's a very nice read
to contact me just drop me an email or
visit my github profile there's actually
so I deployed this game to the real test
net a bit more comprehensive version of
this game if you like to play a figure
this out I'm also you can find me on
Steam 'add which is a social media site
that's actually operating on a
blockchain and of course flix post has a
booth here so if you're interested in
cryptocurrencies come to me if you're
interested in getting hired as a data
scientist and machine learning also come
to us and talk to also other nice people
at the booth sitting there in the back
thank you
[Applause]
thanks a lot for this great talk really
interesting topic so we have plenty of
time for some questions any questions
thank you just a couple of questions the
first one is what if the result of the
program is different between miners what
is the right choice because you thought
that the program will be executed by all
the miners around the world
it cannot be so it's living in this
aetherium sandbox so they all should
come to the same conclusion if some
minor actually computes something else
then it's the faulty transaction and
it's not going to be part of the if the
program is doing something random Akali
your machine yes that's a good question
there is no pure randomness on the
blockchain there are and this is a very
difficult topic to actually getting
random numbers into the blockchain so
the easy way could be just taking the
hash of the block as a random as a
random number but the problem is then
the miners can actually use and exploit
this and so there are ways of so-called
Oracles we're pretty much users send
random numbers to the blockchain as
transactions but there is no pure
randomness in the blockchain so in
principle everybody should come to the
very same conclusion executing the same
program ok so this little machine game
cannot be in the in the okay okay second
question is how can you kill a library
the second act that you show us you
cannot release a new version of the
library and then restore the wallet and
so some of the libraries supports or
some of the smart contract supports
something that's called self-destruct
which pretty much just makes it unusable
and this guy dev ops 1999 actually took
ownership so there was a function claim
ownership which hasn't been done by
parity so the ownership was never
claimed so because they forgot about it
so this guy claimed it and then called
self-destruct and then it was unusable
and yeah okay thank you very much
thanks for the talk I have a question
you said that upon running the smart
contracts there's a
a change of state and I'm asking myself
self how can the blockchain change state
and still remain valid or is that not
like where does it change and so pretty
much so the the the state change for
example would be you have a state
variable that is just an integer right
and you just increase it by one this
could be a state change and and and the
state changes of course initiated by a
transaction so if if you really think
about it all the states have been there
so when you initialized it as zero that
this was a transaction and then if you
added one to it this was another
transaction so you could pretty much
replay this yeah yeah thanks
are you able to use populous in an
interactive way with ipython notebook
for example to actually play something
sort of interactively I haven't tried
this sorry I can't answer that are you
working on any other smart contracts and
right now not not recently but I
actually bought a smart contract where
you can sell your soul on the blockchain
okay sounds fun yeah so far I only did
some silly projects like this snowball
game sorry hey thanks for the talk
as I see it like Russians are trying to
decentralize the not have like one
Authority in the center who controls
everything so you have like a lot of
different parts who control it and like
this is testing that like this in the so
dirty frame like the code is correctly
executed and it's not buggy or stuff
like that but like who develops like the
compiling for the so let's also I'm
sorry there's also dirty language like
who's in British Rams this like is it
like officers deployed and you can see
everything yeah so everything is open
source to the solidity compilers open
source
I think the etherium get up has already
13,000 commits or something like that so
yeah so everything is open source
because then back
in the compiler itself could also be
really costly right yeah so I think the
current compiler version is all point
when t4 so actually what we didn't do
here but what you should always do when
you program stuff and solidity is
actually named the compiler version you
want your code to compile with so that
you don't break though introduce some
some backwards compatible breaks if you
use the newer compiler to actually
deploy the stuff later or a fixed fix of
it yeah hi I also have two questions
actually so the first one is regarding
Popular's is it actively maintained
right now because I use it a couple
awhile ago and it was as you mentioned
hard to install and then I was you as
you were using it there were also some
kind of dependency errors and so on
so what is a status right now and so as
far as I know it's actively maintained
so I think recently a half year ago so
they transferred the ownership to the
actual etherium foundation so now
populous is part of the etherium github
repository so yes and also the second
question would be when we are
interacting with the actual contract
what do you normally use used to use
populace for that or is that a let's say
web drive or web 3pi you can also use or
how do you do it and so let's assume
that it is deployed to the blockchains
and then of course I wouldn't use
populous anymore but unfortunately
something like JavaScript to actually
access it and then there's a web 3
library which is like the new Internet
and you can use that then in JavaScript
to actually connects to the to your
application on the blockchain and and
you can see on my github profile how I
did it
although again I'm not a JavaScript
developer so it might actually look like
horrible to the experts I but I managed
to actually get a website talk to my
application before it relates question
for the deployment itself you use
populous then and sort of stuff actually
I did because it was not so big I used
this remix IDE to directly deploy it
because then you can immediately play
around in remix and send transactions to
it and of course especially when you
when you start deploying stuff to the
main net you've you would
of course first deploy to the test net
and there Etha is basically for free
there are like lots of ways to get free
ether there and then you can test off
and the nice thing about remix is you
can immediately call functions of your
contract and see if it behaves the way
it should in sort of like an end-to-end
testing fashion any questions hi thanks
for the nice explanation I'm wondering
about mechanisms to prevent malicious
code you mentioned a few examples so
what for example would prevent me from
releasing lots of contracts to have
miners calculate prime numbers ah that's
pretty good and very good question so
the problem with or everything you
deploy and all the computations they do
not come for free so there's a whole
concept of gas on this blockchain sukham
which I spared out since I only have
half an hour but pretty much every
computation you do on the blockchain you
have to pay in the end
with etherium so if you do a lots of
computation let's say you do a while
true and then you have to pay for it and
there's a maximum amount of money that
that you can pay so your while true it's
just gonna be a very expensive way to
like burn money and then it fails at
some point so it doesn't run forever
yeah sorry so thanks again no more
questions right so I should say two
things like there will be lunch soon a
and B there's the retro computer from
the keynote in the morning like the
Cobra set up in the room the next room
here and you can play some retro games
there like a manic miner or something
kind of Bitcoin
you